want to know how to turn waste into  wealth in Nigeria waste management is  poor so littering is a major problem but  when plastic waste doesn't break down it  creates serious threats to both health  and the environment an initiative from  waste to wealth decided to do something  about the problem the women involved  collect discarded plastic bags then  clean and dry them after that the bags  are cut into strips and knitted into  accessories such as handbags mats and  even laptop bags  [Music]  the initiative helps women learn new  skills provides them with an additional  source of income and makes the  environment just a little bit cleaner